la colère gronde sur la place de
l'abbaye de cluny la réouverture du
marché ne s'est pas passé dans le calme
les commerçants vendant des produits
manufacturés exclu par la mairie ont
organisé une manifestation pour dénoncer
ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
injustice là le maire a carrément nous a
exclus
il a fait un plan de marche et qui date
du 23 mars et pas de pas de maintenant
et nous il nous a carrément annoncé
notre arrêt de travail par le jsl voilà
parlée par les journaux au total douze
commerçants se sont vus interdits de
marché seuls les états l'alimentaire ont
pu s'installer
une décision justifiée selon le maire
par la nécessité de respecter les
mesures sanitaires
on a fait un cheminement on a essayé
d'installer les 60 et quelques chalands
qui concerne qui concerne l'alimentaire
et le manufacturés était plutôt à 10 ans
à un ensemble de deux de marchands qui
allait allonger le temps de parcours
puisqu'on a limité à 100 personnes le
le nombre de présents dans le marché et
il faut qu'une rotation
donc on a forcément éviter la
diversification et les premiers qui ont
effectivement eu à pâtir se sont évadés
facture et cette situation devrait être
provisoire la municipalité s'est engagée
à trouver une solution pour le début du
mois de juin
en attendant le marché de cluny ne
proposera que des produits alimentaires